what went wrong it is the putin system that
went wrong in this putin system everything uh is
based on actually one factor which is
survival of putting us as president of russia
in most of cases system putin has doomed this
part of the operation to failure why because
putin has assigned his favorites into specific
positions within the russian armed forces
so nobody is going to challenge him if he's got a
bad idea if he says you know that i think this is
what happens is it very unlikely that the generals
are going to be like oh hold on a second because
if we do this and x is going to happen the problem
is this is the way you see it and this is the way
plenty of other people see it but putin in his own
position he's constantly seeing himself surrounded
by competition by contra hence by opposition or
whatever you know some kind of threat for him
it's different from his point of view and this
is what we have to keep in mind that putin sees
these things entirely differently than you
do than anybody else does putin is putin
he's not you he's not me he's not somebody else
he's just put him for the best it's better or
in the interest of politicians and the economy
it's better to fight a war to profit not to win
because if you fight to win you you know
you send 1000 artillery pieces to ukraine
ukraine defeats russia tomorrow in the morning
and the voice over party's over yeah and what then
nobody's earning me anything from that nobody
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm francis
foster i'm constantine kissin and this is a
show for you if you want honest conversations with
fascinating people our brilliant guest today is a
military analyst and historian who's been one of
the most objective voices covering the conflict
in ukraine tom cooper welcome to trigonometry
thank you very much very nice to be with you oh
well it's great to have you on the show so let's
talk about the conflict we wanted to start by
uh just recapping from the beginning for people
who maybe saw the initial events didn't really
follow everything that happened so can you just
talk us through what happened in the initial
phase of the russian invasion yeah sure what
happened early on was that uh there was an attempt
uh obviously not even properly planned but but
driven by putin's demands for russian or selected
parts of the russian armed forces to overrun the
ukrainian leadership to to knock out specific
parts of of of or paralyzed actually actually
uh parts of ukrainian armed forces but
foremost to to to to overrun and and to
decapitate ukrainian political leadership
which means performance government and the
idea was obviously to to land on four uh major
airports around kiev and from there to to to
drive into downtown kiev to better kill or at
least arrest the government and replace it but
some by somebody who would have been friendlier to
putin it was the original idea and because of this
the initial uh ballistic and cruise missile
strikes are not as intensive or as uh
as or as effective as they might have been if
there was a wish to really knock out the ukrainian
armed forces right from the start and to to to
destroy them so to say their leadership as well
the idea was obviously to to capture the
government and that everything was depending
on the dissolution capturing the government of
on removing it and obviously there was a lot of
illusion about uh ukrainians so to say
rising to to to to greet the russians
coming in and eventually three days later
to help to hold military parades in in
kiev and kaki when everything is fine and
uh great and ukraine is now russia again
it's it's really interesting the the way you
put that because it's inverted it's in very
simple terms now i'm going to ask you
a layman question tom and take this
as broadly or as as as you want to but what went
wrong because when the when the invasion started
i think there were a lot of people thinking well
this is you know this is a mighty power of russia
against ukraine they've got this
huge army they've got the weaponry
they've got the men why hasn't it gone
to plan what when what went wrong uh
it is the putin system that went wrong in this
putin system everything is based on actually one
factor which is survival of putin as as
president of russia retaining him in power
so he can continue collecting cuts from
or cut from all the possible enterprises
from the state and so on so in reaching himself
maintaining himself in power and his fencing power
so in order for this system to
survive they have to lie all the time
and one of the lies is that ukrainians would
be some sort of wealth more than brotherly
people to russia and because of this they
would be looking forward to to be very unsc
russia and that they would uh greet the russian
troops and that they're they're controlled by
some sort of nazi regime uh which is suppressing
them terrorizing and genociding russians and so on
so this basic idea was a big lie and it
came so far that even putin lied to himself
he he fell for his own illusions this is what went
wrong and because of his own illusions he sent the
spetsnaz and and the vdb this is airborne russian
airborne troops into ukraine under entirely wrong
conditions he has sent them in expecting them
to meet only light resistance if at all and
you know to rapidly achieve uh their their that
their aims and this is what didn't work because
ukrainians those and even if there was lots of
chaos and even if there was you know shocked
and surprised by this initial attack they they
they took up arms and defended and fought back
this is what what was unexpected for the russians
and tom when you talk about things going wrong uh
when you describe the initial phase of the attack
which is attempting to take over the airport and
decapitate the regime it sounds a little bit to me
like what a superpower might do to a small country
in the middle east you come in you remove the
the head of the regime and then you take over and
obviously it didn't go down that way but after
that we obviously saw uh these columns coming
in from the north uh and the big attack in
the south and obviously the push in the east
and those haven't even in the initial phase
they were they made some progress but they
were repelled can you talk to us about that
phase of the invasion as well yes of course uh
yes it was an idea you know of a quick quick
takeover that was fundamental to the entire plan
if if there was really a plan the way the things
looked like putin didn't even discuss this plan
with shoigu and gerasimov he simply ordered
specific field commanders commanders of of
combined arms armies of the russian ground forces
to let's say for example move to brigade a from
place b to place c and uh capture the government
it was that simple and then the idea was to follow
up you know because this light airborne
troops and special troops they cannot hold
any kind of area for for an extended period of
time they cannot do that on their own because
they're likely armed and they cannot do that
without supplies this meant that they have to
follow the light troops and this is also part of
standard russian warfighting doctrine so to say
uh to that to be followed by by ground troops
which in the case of russia is always mechanized
units they do not call them mechanized
they call them tank units or they call them
motorized infantry or whatever else but they
are mechanized units and they have to follow
and to secure to help the the the special forces
and and airborne forces to secure the the areas
they have taken during the first initial strike
and then came again what what happened was next
was twofold so to say in most of cases
system putin has doomed the this part of the
operation to failure why because putin
has assigned his favorites into specific
position positions within the russian armed forces
favorites who were permitted to enrich themselves
on condition of unaccountability to
anybody except to putin and on condition of
providing him with his cut from from all the
money that they were pocketing all the time
this is how putin system system putin works works
so that you appoint your friends and and less of
family members but foremost friends or aides or
associates or whoever into specific positions
where they are cashing from uh huge contracts
there's a signing with the state and then they're
overpricing all the time and from this this
income they are financing putin and when he needs
something he just needs to call and he's getting
his money or his favors or whatever else in in
return for this for appointing people to such
positions and it's the same in the in the army
on the other side because of this the army has
never completed its reforms it's it has never
really converted itself into a professional
force and the the the generals commanding it
are incompetent they are putin's favorites but
they are not there because they because of merits
of because of their skills or capabilities but but
because they are putin's favorites sorry for this
reason are you tired of using bulky old wallets
giving you a bulge where you don't want it to be
my old wallet was massive so it brought all the
ladies to the yard which was a huge distraction
and got in the way of my esteemed work on
trigonometry bridge wallets have an incredible
solution for you this is mine sleek stylish and
with an industrial look to it you can fit 12 cards
with cash on the back using a clip like this one
or a strap we've got one for the whole team i've
got one francis has one even our producer anthem
has one but he's from liverpool so he flogged his
on the black market the great thing about ridge
is that they give you a lifetime guarantee
which means if you want you can have only one
wallet for the rest of your life ridge are so
confident in the quality of their product they
will give you 45 days to test drive their wallets
that means you can get the wallet use it and if
you don't like it you can return it within 45
days and that's not all for every dollar you
spent on the ridge wallets website you'll be
entered into a competition to win a brand new
upgraded ford bronco or if you can't drive like
france's then you can win 75 000 in cash winners
will be announced in october so get spending
because ridge are such great guys they're
going to give you 10 off and free worldwide
shipping and returns to take advantage of this
incredible offer go to ridge.com forward slash
trigger that's ridge.com forward slash trigger and
use our special code which is of course trigger
tom isn't also part of the problem as well
like you've got a guy like putin at the top
who to put it mildly is a little bit ruthless
right so nobody is going to challenge him if he's
got a bad idea if he says you know that i think
this is what happens is it very unlikely that the
generals are going to be like oh hold on a second
because if we do this and x is going to happen
the problem is this is the way you see it and this
is the way plenty of other people see it but putin
in his own position he's constantly seeing himself
surrounded by by competition by contra hands
by opposition or whatever you know some kind of
threat for him and this is why he has established
for example the ross guardia ross guardia is a
paramilitary force which is responsible solely
to putin it is not responsible to to the minister
of defense in moscow but it is as possible solely
to put him why because he wanted to make sure
that in the case that the armed forces would
stage a coup against him he hasn't it's his
own military force to counter such an operation
so you have the lost guardian
as a sort of pretorian guard
for putting responsible solution to putin you
don't you do not you barely see it fighting on
the frontlines in ukraine but it's always in the
rear securing the back the rear areas you know the
towns behind the front line villages behind
the front line checking what is the local
population doing but also keeping an eye on the
russian armed forces fighting on the front line
so therefore you know it's different from his
point of view and this is what we have to keep
in mind that putin sees these things entirely
differently than you do uh than anybody else
does putin is putin he's not you he's not
me he's not somebody else he's just putin
well tom as someone who's from russia i hear
everything you're saying and it's very familiar
to me both about putin and the the military
hierarchy and so on but people would argue that
uh while obviously there were failures from the
russian invasion at the beginning they did manage
to capture significant territory in the northeast
around harcouth they managed to capture a huge
swathe of land in the south uh that's the point
yes yes they managed to eventually grind down
their resistance in marijuana in the southeast
on the sea of azov and capture that they've made
significant progress in the donbass it's cost them
a lot but they have over the last six months yes
eventually they had to withdraw from kiev and so
on but they've still made a lot of progress you
would i think a lot of people would credibly argue
why were they able to do that that's the point
there was a part of the only part of the russian
what is initial putin's plan for for for takeover
of ukraine that that did work was in the south
they are also the most combat experienced
element of the russian ground forces
was deployed this is the 58th combined
arms army and next to it there was a 49th
combined arms army these two armies stormed
from crimean from the occupied crimean peninsula
towards the stores north another 58 had a very
important task which was to reach zachariah and
to to reach mario paul from the west from the west
and uh the 49th had at least an as an
important task which was to to take care zone
take me collide and then advance all the way to
the border with moldova there there is a part of
moldova east of the the nest river controlled
by russian separatists so-called sansnistria
and in that way putin was aiming not only to to
take away the entire ukrainian coast away from
ukraine to bring it under his control but also to
establish land con connection to the transnistria
and these two armies have thanks to treachery
obvious treachery on the part of uh
i don't know exactly which treason
yes uh exactly treason by on the part of higher
ranking officers in the ukrainian armed forces
it has worked flawlessly really they have reached
castle within two or three days no problem they
have they have uh closed the siege of mario within
two days the only thing that didn't work uh was
the capture of zaparoja but otherwise it that this
is what brought the biggest conquest in comparison
uh to this advance in the south you have advanced
in in in kiev area and chinese areas in the north
and in kharkiv all of them failed the 35th uh
combined arms army did manage to reach outskirts
of kiev but in turn was almost cut off from its uh
supply lines and there was this huge because there
was only one highway it could use to reach kiers
so it it was slow down bogged down by its own
supply problems the 41st combined arms army which
was advancing on chinese fell apart in the process
of advancing on cheney in the face of relativity
resistance by by one and a half something like
one and a half ukrainian brigades so it fell apart
by advancing for 70 to 80 kilometers to change it
uh you have the first gods tanks army the the
elite of of of the of the russian armed forces
it fell apart by passing by sumi and trying
to advance towards uh kiev from the east
and uh worst of all the two armies that
were advancing that that the task with
capturing kharkiv they also actually fall up fell
apart in the process i mean there were only two
ukrainian brigades offering serious resistance
in the karaki area during the first week of war
and they didn't manage to to to to drive around
the city they didn't even manage to drive they did
manage to drive into the city for a few hours
and they would destroy it to the last almost
so this part northern part of the invasion failed
miserably this is where the russian armed forces
fade on putin from putin's point of view and this
is why he's terribly mad about them already since
months also why he's punishing them by these
constant orders for assaulting heavily fortified
urban areas of eastern ukraine ever since on the
contrary in the south he just you know ordered
okay you have taken what you have secure it and
that's fine with me they are not punished so much
they are even reinforced by the by airborne troops
now in august so tom looking at the situation now
do you think the russians are going to be happy
with what they have would that would they regard
this invasion as a failure at this particular
moment okay when we talk about russians i'm again
i am a little bit insistent in these regards there
is putin yeah then there are russian nationalists
chauvinists extremists whatever we want to call
them and then there are russians okay now putin
is not happy but because he's all the time forced
to downsize his aims for what he wants to do in
ukraine initially he want to take over all of
the country then just the country east of the
nipro river then then now you know just secure
luhansk and donetsk and and careson and zapologia
meanwhile he is even to to less than this
and so on and so on then you have the russian
extremists who whom who are actually misused by
putin for his purposes this is where you get the
story about our history of russia and ukraine
is so complex and blah blah blah blah blah
that day dreaming about things you know and
have no actually no other purpose but keeping
or helping uh keeps putting in power most of them
have actually no say in in any kind of decision
making they're just you know led to to cash
their income from tv appearances and so on or
by uh being representatives in the domain in the
russian parliament then you have the rest of the
russians and what is this rest of the russians
actually doing this is majority of the population
over 90 nobody really knows because putin
wouldn't let us know wouldn't even let him
then know what do they want so some of them
are probably pro putin or at least for russia
against ukraine and really convinced that ukraine
is controlled by some kind of nazi regime others
apparently do not care they want to survive they
they are fighting their everyday life for survival
fighting their every everyday struggle
for survival nothing else you know
so it is i'm making quite distinctions between
this but crucial point is putin is not happy with
what he has achieved or failed to achieve so far
and he is definitely determined to to continue you
know holding as much of ukraine as possible and
tom this brings us nicely onto last week's events
where there was a huge counter attack there was a
small counter attack in the south near hassan and
a big counter attack which was very successful
in the north and i am someone who's observing
this conflict and i i have my loyalties but i also
tried to be objective about it as well of course
and while i was very happy to see the
counter-attack succeed in the way that it did
i was a bit concerned that people in the
west got over excited about it because yes
the russians abandoned a lot of military
equipment yes ammunition yes land but they
didn't lose huge numbers of troops there was no
major encirclements how significant first of all
was the counter-attack what should people in the
west who are lay people like us watching this
take away from it is this some a lot of people
seem to think this is like the end of the war
can you tell us what this actually means it is
just another episode in this war nothing else uh
i have to even if trying to explain this to
a layman i have to to go into a little bit
of technical details for example the number of
brigades deployed in cassonne for this contra
offensive you know in late august is the
same like the number of brigades deployed
for this uh counteroffensive in eastern
kharkiv a few days later so the force
is not that different or anything where there
is a difference is that in in eastern khaki
the ukrainians have managed to find a sector
frontline where the russian artillery was not that
over overwhelming them as it is on other important
parts of the frontline and this enabled them to
concentrate virtually lots of forces which is
some seven or eight brigades on a very small area
to overpower quickly overpower the russian
frontline and punch through to get into the rear
of the russian front line in cassonne they didn't
manage that feat yet in cassandra all the time
trying to bridge the russian frontline but so far
have with few temporary except exceptions they
have not managed to to to reach this breakthrough
at operational level as it's called in in military
uh vocabulary so what happened then
in casson they are they have moved
lots of foreign but overall the russian armed
forces in casson are still well depleted but
intact they are still operational what happened
in eastern kharkiv is that once they have breached
the front line which was a sector of frontline
which was poorly uh occupied by the russians
they have managed to drive through very deep into
the russian bank what then happened was inertia so
so-called inertia in response to several russian
counterattacks all of which came from the north
the ukrainian troops moved or you could involve
ukrainian brigades moved towards north too
it is also saw that by trying to move from
from uh balaclaea towards the south towards
the eastern they were slowed down by ever
stronger units of uh russian army so instead
on on issue they went for coupons instead this
has collapsed the entire northern section of
the russian front line really threw everybody
into chaos and this is what resulted in this
massive retreat and and lots of vehicles being
abandoned and so on and ukrainians liberating
you know dozens 30 40 50 60 villages cupiansk
and everything else reaching the oscar river
but the actual aim of that operation
that is a guess i do not have any kind
of evidence for this but this is logical
was actually to to drive into the rear into
the back of the first guards tank army in
the easom area and this is what they have
they have not initially managed as first there
was too much resistance and second the road
network between kupiansk and issum there's
only one highway it is not a direct highway
it is not running around the roskill river so they
had a problem to approach this area and then they
finally approached ezio they have uh passed by the
town because there were too many russian forces in
inside the town and they were still resisting
too fiercely and at that point in time it would
have been crucial for the ukrainian troops on
the southern southern side of the resulting
bulge so to say to punch through the uh to punch
to the russian front lines and to close the
uh the trap so to say around the first gods
army they have attempted to do so but they
didn't manage that and this is why the the first
guards army actually managed to to to run away to
escape of course it has lost what 100 150 tanks
and 100 armored fighting vehicles and so on but
if you check the losses you can see that russia's
lost very few are theory during this operation it
is something like 1820 artillery pieces this is
nothing one should keep in mind that the entire
russian frontline is held together the fact
by their a theory but a superior artillery
so if they would have suffered a loss of 100 heavy
guns that would have been a massive loss for the
russians but tanks and infantry fighting vehicles
and armored personnel carriers they do not putin
cannot care less because it's not hurting him he
has ten thousand of these stored somewhere you
know around russia he can always replace them but
artillery pieces this would have been much harder
to replace and on the contrary they have managed
to extract most of their artillery uh towards swat
to the stratovey area and uh those as much as an
immense success because especially because you
know it is uh the first major ukrainian offense
that is that has really been successful on its
own so to say the ukrainians have really beaten
the russians and this is why events is important
this operation is far from ending this war it
is just another episode in this war the first
gods army has started itself the russians have
established a new front line along the oscar river
that's it you know now the ukrainians have to find
another place where they are going to to attack
again and perhaps achieve something similar in the
meantime we shouldn't forget that russians remain
on offensive on initiative all the way further
down south you know southeastern ukraine from
they are still attacking bachmat they are still
attacking along the former line of control
and so on and so on so it is far away
far away from from from ending this war
and tom are there causes for optimism because
i i was reading some of your articles on medium
there's a lot of i think it's um weaponry that the
ukrainians haven't have haven't yet received yet
which means that they'll be strengthened when
it comes to the battles in the coming months
for cautious optimism the point is that
yes the usa has promised yet more weaponry but
most of that is ammunition ukraine is not about
to receive yet more heavier theory and that is
the problem russia remains superior in regards
of artillery and vastly superior to ukraine just
like before these two operations this is what
is holding quests on together russian forces in
question together this is why their frontline is
not collapsing because they still have more
artillery than ukrainians over there which
means they they're still capable of hampering
ukrainian attempts to drive between their russian
uh fortifications between russian stoneholds and
outflank them and cut them off from their supply
lines this is this is the reason why that's so
important the artillery and we don't really don't
the west hasn't still hasn't taken care to provide
enough artillery to ukraine this is not going to
change anytime soon why not tom why not well
as we can see it's a little bit complex issue
for example united states and the european
part of the nato have lots of old artillery
pieces caliber 155 millimeter in their reserve
they are stored for 20 years sometimes longer
and so on they're not in use but they're not
delivering them what they do deliver are artillery
pieces or weapon system which are currently in
production why because this is bringing profit
it means that the governments
whether the u.s or governments of the
european part of the nato can spend to buy yet
more weapons that are currently in production from
from the defense sector this is pure profit profit
nothing else this is the only solar reason is
sector the companies which are selling these
weapons which are manufacturing them sorry
this is like in every in every other aspect of our
economic life they are bribing governments to buy
weapons not to deliver reserve or old ones from
the reserve that's how it works what i was going
to ask you then i suppose the obvious question is
does the west actually want ukraine to win yes but
the west does want to ukraine to win but it's
uh in the west you do not have the politicians
in the west they do not have this clear idea
of fighting war to win for them fighting a war
is an opportunity to profit for for companies for
private and corporate uh interests supporting them
paying their elections election campaigns and so
on to to to for such interest to to profit so you
have the same situation like all the time since
vietnam already vietnam afghanistan iraq you know
for the west it's better or in the interest
of politicians and the economy it's better
to fight a war to profit not to win because if
you fight to win you you know you send 1 000
artillery pieces to ukraine ukraine defeats
russia tomorrow in the morning that is now
hyperbola and uh the war is over party's over yeah
and what then nobody's earning anything from that
nobody but if you you know keep ukraine afloat and
supply it with weapons which are currently under
production your sponsors in the rear the guys
in the shade in the shadow they are profiting
everything is fine you know and we go on just
like nothing happened the only thing disturbing
all of this the party is is this story with with
uh gas deliveries and and high energy prices oh
gosh this is a little bit disturbing because you
know the population is against this and we have to
do something in the curb the high energy prices so
we have to keep this under under control in order
at least to pretend we are trying to keep them
under control and so on although it would be very
easy but well and let's live our democracy in the
economy and tom what difference is winter going
to make to this conflict because it's around the
corner in a couple of months and ukrainian winters
are notoriously bitter yeah well what is making
it's going to bring bigger advantages for ukraine
primary reason so far why the russian armed
forces were relatively successful which is
actually just one segment of russian
armed forces this is the ground forces
have been successful the last let's say since
april since it since it got warmer in ukraine is
the combination between their their uavs orland 10
in particular and their artillery holland 10 is a
very rather or rather primitive military
system it's not even military it's actually
only the the few region wings are military
grade everything else is actually bought
on open market you know canon cameras
and canon video cam video cameras and
and ecm systems everything they install into
these uavs is civilian grade equipment which means
that it cannot work at temperatures below
five degrees centigrade which in turn means
as soon as it's freezing outside the russians
are going to be blind along the battlefield
and then they they're going to have huge problems
with finding the ukrainians along with that this
is why russians have now rushed to buy uavs from
from iran because iran thanks to chinese support
and technical support and know-how and even
organizational production in iran uh iran is
capable of delivering military-grade uavs so the
russians are obviously planning to replace their
their own uavs which are useless in winter
by iranian uavs we're going to see if this
is going to be effective or not but general
ukraine should be on advantage so that's very
interesting because i would have thought that it
would you know it would help the russians because
they push them back and they can and look again
i'm a layman but you know you can restrict you
know the flow of goods and whatever else he just
thinks the russians are invulnerable to the cold
yeah yeah a long time around me yeah but i i
would have thought that they'd it would it would
help them to kind of not starve the ukrainians out
but certainly make things far more uncomfortable
for them i mean we have to distinguish between
ukrainian armed forces and ukrainian civilians
we have there are millions and millions of
ukrainians in eastern ukraine feeling this
war and their you know direct impact upon their
everyday life they are going to be freezing
they are going to be hungry and so on and they are
not going to survive without extensive aid from
from the west and from here and so on this is one
part of the story but ukrainian armed forces they
have no problem they are already in the process
of distributing winter clothing and with winter
equipment on their to their troops so this is
not going to be that much of a problem floating
food fuel as you can see the ukrainian uh supply
system is working perfectly and the russians have
massive problems just trying to find it you know
in order to hit it for example from the air with
with whose missiles baristic missiles and so
on they're not successful in these regards
so this is not a problem for the ukrainian armed
forces on the contrary because of the system putin
and because of all the lies at which they are
feeding their people for for decades already
and because now they're starting to realize the
extension of these lies the morale is very low
and then you have system putin in regards of
command system where the the putin is bypassing
all the normal chain of command in the armed
forces and all the issuing direct orders upon
field commanders which is spraying everything he's
throwing you know every single day he's throwing
the the russian military doctrine and strategy out
of the window ignoring them completely and issuing
ever new orders for assaults on specific
objects and so on which result in heavy
casualties but he can't care about this
why because he thinks that his favorites
owe him a favor or returning a favor
all the favors he has granted to them
and so this is a vicious circle in inside russia
which is going to result you know in in further
debacles like this one in eastern karaki
now this is going to happen time and again
however in between of this or such tobaccos they
are going to be you know periods of many months
where the ukrainians will have to maneuver to find
such weak spots in russian frontlines to in order
to exploit them that is going to be crucial for
the coming winter hey do you want better mental
health i'm from russia we don't have mental health
so how do you deal with mental health you drink
vodka then go out and wrestle bear if you live you
feel better if you die you're not real men what
about the bear's feelings it's russian bear it
has no feelings people don't always realize that
physical symptoms like headaches teeth grinding
and even digestive issues can be indicators of
stress and let's not forget about doom scrolling
not sleeping enough sleeping too much under eating
and overeating sleeping too much under eating this
is western disease therapy has really helped me
in my life to concentrate and focus it's really
important to have someone impartial who you can
talk to about the tricky issues that you're
struggling to deal with therapy has played a
really important role in helping me to deal with
my adhd and become better in all areas of my life
why is he telling them how weak he is drink
vodka feel better better help is customized
online therapy that offers video phone and even
live chat sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if you
don't want to trigonometry funds get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com forward slash
trigger especially if they're not real men that's
t t e r h e l p dot com slash trigger tom
just a very quick question before i move
on the conversation uh what is your
estimate for casualties on both sides
uh i prefer not to mix into into such
discussions because we do not have any
kind of firm figures you know we have we do have
official claims de facto from from ukraine we have
an external team from russian side but we
have nothing really dependable in this regards
i do estimate that ukrainian casualties are
actually higher than russian i don't know how much
but it is it plays in the nature of things they
were they were lightly armed uh and they are fully
protected especially early during the war and as
much as more combat experience than the russians
meanwhile they are on offensive when you're
in offensive you're automatically suffering
heavier casualties and so on and so on but
generally i'm sorry for people who have died
i'm sorry for those who even more for those who
who were maimed or injured in whatever other way
but i find it pointless to talk about casualties
because it's it's leading nowhere we're discussing
propaganda from both sides and discussing
propaganda is pointless sorry for that no no of
course i agree that makes sense that's why i asked
you because i have no idea even though i keep
a pretty close eye on the conflict because you
like you say both sides you know they have uh the
point of communication and war is to win it's not
to communicate the truth so uh you talked about
you talked about um the civilian infrastructure
and so on and one of the things we saw as
it seems to me at least correct me if i'm wrong
is the immediate reaction from russia to the
harcav counter assault has been to attack civilian
infrastructure power lines water supply lines etc
what do you make of that is that just you know the
russian regime being angry and lashing out is it
a more strategic what's going on there it's part
of that you know primarily it's a punishment
you shouldn't forget that as xkgb putin is a
foremost an extortionist he's going to blackmail
everybody and everything he is ruling by
blackmail he came to power by blackmail
he's ruling by blackmail and his sole political
program is you know whom can i blackmail today and
uh it is the same in this case okay you ukrainians
are resisting me then have something of this
here is your resistance i'm destroying your your
infrastructure it's as simple as that punishment
as i see and one of the things we talked about
earlier in the conversation that i really wanted
to discuss with you is you mentioned that in
addition to putin's regime and ordinary russians
there are also another sliver of people in
between who are actually protesting against putin
privately or in their private telegram channels
and whatever who are saying that putin is weak
and he's not doing enough and what he needs to
do is announce full mobilization put the economy
on a war footing mobilize every man between 18 and
45 or whatever it would be 35 and announce that
this is no longer a special military operation
this is a full war russia is at war and use the
entirety of the russian economy and military to
defeat ukraine that's what they're calling for
that hasn't happened so far do you think it will
no it's not going to happen there are plenty of
reasons there are plenty of reasons for this
the first is it would cost putin putin lots of
his money which means what he is extracting from
the russian economy and state every single day
that would cost it would cost him too much
for this second tom how much money can a man
need he's already one of the richest people
in the world i don't know ask putin sorry
i don't know i mean he there are stories about
him bunkering what 800 billion somewhere in the
west or in china and wherever i don't know how
much more he needs i don't know but he obviously
has no end of needs in these regards okay but
let's let's get back to your earlier question
uh the next problem is that the russian state and
administration is as we call it in german kaput
it's broken down i mean it's it's
bordering on collapse it's not working
so let's say you try to move he announces
general mobilization first of all he would
have a massive problem just with you know how
many people would actually follow that call
there are very informed russians who say more
than 50 would would ignore it it would be an
absolute catastrophe for for putting then secondly
this would result in in huge gatherings of armed
people around russia which is which is a threat
for putin sorry whether they are controlled or not
by officers of his armed forces is
secondary it is a threat for putin
thirdly what would russian armed forces get from
that they would get let's say one million perhaps
two million of recruits okay and who would train
this all these people who would keep them supplied
who would keep them you know warm who tell them
that to sleep by night there are too few officers
and and non-commissioned commissioned officers
left in the russian armed forces to do this kind
of job organization and logistics for such a
huge army so it would take you know they will
get millions of people into the army and these
would you know stand around the barracks and
we don't know what to do because there are
too few commanders to command them actually
just to command them not to talk about training
them and then you have you know all of this is
rolling further who's going to issue them with
weapons who is going to train them on weapons who
is going to form coherent units from them you know
from from platoon up to company level to battalion
level to brigade level to divisional level there
is not enough of of officers there is not enough
of non-commissioned officers left in
the russian armed forces to do the job
so what they are doing is to recruit from
different associations veteran associations
this is these are people who are already who
are already trained and they have the history of
service in armed forces and they are already you
know it's easier to refresh their training in two
or three weeks and send them to the frontline this
is what they are doing most of such people are
ending serving in in private military companies
which is one of the things which that is that is
i would say quite ignored in the west just how
many battalion tactical groups for example reduced
private military company or wagner which is much
better known have on the frontlines meanwhile how
dependent on their operations is put in
meanwhile this is something nobody's talking
about everybody's talking about russian armed
forces but whenever you check all the major
advances of russia over the last four or five
months it's always a private military company
that was that led the advanced you know the let
the penetration of the ukrainian front class
so but tom working a different way it's
worked there is a mobilization already
to the pmc yes i want to come back to the
pmc but go ahead francis no but tom see
maybe i take a romanticized approach to this
and and i think to myself you know nobody is
going to fight harder for their country than
a ukrainian soldier or a russian soldier what
you're saying is these people are effectively
mercenaries but doesn't that mean that they're
going to have less allegiance to the courts that
they're fighting for because they're they're
there to get paid essentially what should what
should an average russian fight for in ukraine
it's as simple as that he i mean okay
putin is promising you know you can take
loot with you and if you get killed you
your family is going to get a new ladder
oh great would you like to go fighting somewhere
for a new ladder i wouldn't as simple as that so
you know what what putin is getting is something
so to say outcasts in his armed forces or or
weapons freaks you know such people they
are already serving in armed forces when
they got get shot away what he has to
find some kind of replacements so the
easiest way to finding a replacement it's not
a massive general mobilization but recruiting
veterans and this is what he is doing and you this
is how he come already so far that even veterans
of the war of the soviet were in afghanistan in
1980s are serving on the frontlines i mean these
are people in their 60s yeah so this is how it
works in russia because normal way doesn't work
no what is normal to you or to me here in europe
in the uk or in the united states is not normal
in russia in russia has its own normality and
this is entirely different than in our case
you shouldn't forget that 50 of russians do
not even have a water closet inside their home
they have to go outside
into into some kind of cabin
okay what should they what should they fight for
in in in in ukraine it's either for loot or for
lada in the case they can't get killed
or something else but they they're not
for money or for money in a private military
company as you say so this is what i was going
to ask you about because i agree with you i've
been following and it seems to me that all the
breakthroughs certainly in the donbass are being
made by these private military companies so why is
there combat effectiveness higher because i see
videos of evgeny praguerian the head of wagner
recruiting people from prisons now how are
they that's what they're doing how are they
having such success relative to the rest of the
russian armed forces well relative success because
they are drafting they are recruiting veterans
people who have combat experience who have served
you for take for whether you take wagner or or
or redhoot these are the leading private military
companies in russia especially but let's ignore
wagner which is well known for a while let's
take reduced reduce is based right next to major
airborne units in in peskov area so this means
their neighbor as soon as you the day after you
have quit your service in in the airborne forces
you exit your barracks and vis-a-vis there is a
there is a base of redhot pmc so what shall you do
russia is huge perhaps you have already
some other job perhaps you are going to
find a job in some kind of private security
company inside russia or not but let's say
you know significant percentage of cases you're
not going to kind to find any kind of job or at
least nothing better paid but what red hood is
offering so you go to private military company
and by serving such a company at earlier times
you had an outlook of you know seeing something
of the world serving in syria libya in central
african republic republic excuse me i'm i'm
smiling about this or laughing about this because
you know for average russian it is a lot they do
not manage to travel around they do not have the
money for that it's true yeah so what do you have
now if you have incentives okay let's go serving
in redhote and redwood is full of former airborne
troops veteran airborne troops and they are sent
there that are sent to kiev together with with uh
airborne troops and species at the start of the
war nobody's talking about this i don't know why
but they were there they lost an
enter battalion tactical group
in kiev or on approaches to kiev nobody's talking
about that not even ukrainians i don't know why
so it's it's a strange situation actually we i
think we are not paying enough attention at this
aspect of uh russian war effort so to say but
if you if you check the associations of such of
veteran associations of paratroopers urban troops
of kozaks of this and that this is over a million
of people so this is enough you know huge enough
pool for putin to recruit from them and tom why
isn't it if you say that winter is going to favor
ukraine more why isn't putin just going to go
all in and just go right we need to make the
gains now let's go all in let's demoralize them
let's defeat them and let's get this over with
as soon as possible he's doing this all the time
he's doing this all the time the problem is just
that due to put system putin it's not working
he was you know he was promising this kingdom
hypersonic missile which is going to destroy
any kind of enemy which against which there
are no defenses how the nato is crying about we
don't have these defenses against this weapon
and what happens eventually kingship is uh
impossible to to make operational without
western information technologies so what
happens then he fires one in what was it
april or something or march he fires another
one about a few weeks later and then now he
has ordered a third deployment and
the missile just crashed inside russia
it's not working and why is it not
working again because of system putin
imagine running a high technology enterprise
under putin's rule you can't do that because
you need a huge investment of money but putin is
not investing in into the russian economy he's
bunkering his money in somewhere in the west or
in china or wherever so you are now a ceo of let's
say a small enterprise just launch something
in a garage and you want to develop right
it's and uh you want to to make hardware you
need hardware for such an enterprise whether
you get this hardware russia is not manufacturing
it you have to import everything from the west
and this is already a crucial crucial
moment you you constantly need an
intake of western high technology in
order to develop russian high technology
and you have a massive problem with this this
costs a lot of money which you don't have because
you all the time have to pay put in his share
as soon as you are successful as an enterpreneur
in russia you have to put to pay put in his cut
otherwise you lose your enterprise and he appoints
one of his favorites this is what's happening
all the time under portugal actually even for
even earlier so it's not working the system is
not working it's collapsing all the time it takes
ages to collapse completely
but it's collapsing it's in
the best way and i suppose the question leading
on from that tom is how long other is putin
and the russian forces how long are they going
to have the stomach for this fight because this
can't carry on forever surely i don't know i'm not
into predicting future i don't have any kind of a
crystal ball to say but you know sooner or later
it's going there is going to be a big collapse
right now the the situation is still so that
uh that russia is a fatalist or yes how color
else to describe them enough to follow their
orders the mass of russian of uh troops are
you know they're like that okay you know i don't
have my own opinion my superior commander told me
this let's go do that you know what's what he says
let's follow his orders that's the way they think
and when you when you check some of the interviews
of uh russian prisoners of war taken by ukrainian
journalists there is one who is specialized in
such interviews and you even hear from russian
soldiers they say i'm surprised how much are
your troops ukrainian troops free to decide for
themselves what are they going to do you don't
have this you don't you don't even think that
way in russia you you receive your order and you
follow your order period that's it that's what you
do in ukraine you discuss your order with your
superior officer you don't like something you
post a video on facebook and say we have units
so and so we are refusing to fight because our
officer is corrupt or incompetent or sending us
into into into combat without necessary support
this is ukrainian concept and it's work it
works you know actually you don't have you
don't have such a concept at all and tom you were
talking about the military technology side of
things which brings us onto an issue we haven't
discussed yet which is of course sanctions
and i think the lay people in the west think of
sanctions as one thing so military technology and
oil and gas and it all kind of just blends
into one thing and there's a lot of people
saying sanctions have been counterproductive
because russia's oil revenues are going up
talk to us about sanctions are they working
which ones are good which ones are bad
you know what is the future of all of that
and what is the impact on russia today
for the start matter of fact is that putin's enter
military buildup it's a big show actually but
let's call it a military buildup uh was financed
by the west so there's a difference you know for
the last 20 years and now from this point of
view it's more important considering that the
mass of western customers for
russian oil and gas has signed
long-term contracts you stipulate that either you
buy it or you don't buy it but you have to pay
so you have to pay no matter how much have you
have you have you imported from russia so in that
in that regards you know even if let's say let's
say let's take austria's example osteonor would
would say okay i'm i'm canceling my contract
signed last year by our holy chancellor
um who is now working for google by the way uh
and and let's now stop importing russian gas
austria would still have to pay several
billions a year even if not importing
a single ounce of russian gas and that until
2040 which which is what 18 years from now so
ideal situation for putin wait would austria
honor that contract in the current situation
would austria sorry on another contract
would they pay well austere would have to
pay yes it would have to honor it yes what
else you guys take your rules too seriously
it is it is the way the world is made there is no
reason there is no superior reason the god didn't
show himself up and and said oh you're austria i'm
not going to to import russian oil anymore what
else should happen a huge a massive supernatural
or natural catastrophe destroying the whatever but
russia but austria has to to continue importing
and foremost it has to continue paying germany is
the same case france it's italy in front of france
the same case this is why putin hasn't cancelled
these contracts yet he could cancel them like
he has cancelled in the case of the netherlands
in this case he didn't con cancel the contest
because he's profiting anyway from this
and uh okay of course our government could now say
well okay we are going to cancel this contract but
then we have to pay penalties even more so
because the contract stipulates that we have
to pay continue paying whether we buy whether you
import or not so no it's okay so those sanctions
i am assuming are not going to have the effect the
west wants what about military technology transfer
very much it is for example the the freezing of
uh federal russian reserves had put in massive
it took away something 25 percent of his money
uh then high technology freezing high technology
this is by far not exploited enough this this this
field one could really penalize russia much more
in these regards they are still managing to buy
if nothing else from japan and from china you know
okay china is even more reluctant to to sell high
technology to russia these days than japan is or
south korea is so there is still a lot opportunity
in this regard some could still hit russians much
harder in these regards but it shouldn't mean
that sanctions are not hurting russia they are
hurting it badly and we are going to see how much
just during this winter and it starts hurting the
russian population as well uh what's that going
to look like tom when you say that it's hurting
what is that what are we going to see in russia
well in worst case uh what is sometimes around
1917 that russia do not like to be hungry and
freezing in winter it could happen the same
it could could you know could be the same
exactly the same like in 1917 there it
was women working in ammunition factories which
roses first and then the october revolution began
we are going to see perhaps it's going
to happen perhaps not i don't know but
it could happen let's say this way so are you
optimistic about the future tom has this good
better generally i am generally i am because
uh generally i see humanity as a positive
positive i said is uh positively developing
uh appearance in the nature uh i mean we
we are doing lots of idiotic things and
killing our each other and killing the
nature and so on but sooner or later
at least five before 12 you usually
get sane you know after hitting the wall with with
our foreheads some 500 to 1 000 times usually gets
sane and reasonable and and starts doing things
the right way so i think it's going to be this
way in this case as well i'm i'm i said i'm
generally i'm i'm i'm optimistic about the future
well on that happy note at least uh tom we
will wrap it up there we're going to ask you
a couple of questions for our supporters
that they've already submitted for our locals
but before we let you go and by the way thank
you so much for this i'm sure we would love to
have you back when there's more developments
in in in this conflict in the future um but uh
the question we always ask our guests before
we let them go is what is the one thing that
we're not talking about as a society that you
think we really should be except for this war
now i i mean this seriously i i think we
should generally be discussing uh putin's uh
involvement in subverting the interwest
and democracies this is uh that there
are several books at least one of which i could
recommend right away uh this is discussing this
but it's still not enough but he has seriously
subverted our societies i mean from inside out
and uh we are feeling this every
single day and it's not just
in the uk not just in france not just in
austria or germany it's really everywhere but
he's he has the presence behind the curtain so
to say and he's still pulling strings around
this is one of the things and the
other thing what does that look like
what are you talking about putin has a massive
they call this black cash massive amounts of
money on accounts owned by his favorites in
the west and he is with help of this cash he's
influencing even the justice systems of of entire
countries uk in between of this not only usa
but uk and and france and austria and so on so
this these are immense volumes of money which is
using to subvert our societies and this is what i
think should be intensely discussed and sorted out
you know nothing happened so far to anybody
in these regards nobody was you know made
responsible for for for letting himself
or herself being bribed by all this money
but it is actually this destructive for our
societies i agree with you uh tom cooper thank you
so much where can people uh read your uh updates
uh tell everybody where to find your work online
well it's the easiest it's on medium.com if you
check uh ukrainian war and tom cooper you can
easily find a link i mean if i check the link
just a second precisely medium.com uh flash at
it's been an absolute pleasure we're going to uh
have some questions from our local supporters just
afterwards but thank you so much for coming
on the show you've been a wonderful guest and
very illuminating very much my pleasure thank
you very much for for inviting me to this show
and if you've enjoyed our episodes they always go
out on wednesdays and sundays 7 p.m uk time 2 p.m
eastern standard our raw shows go out thursday
friday and saturday and for those of you who like
your trigonometry on the go it's also available
as a podcast take care and see you soon guys uh
barten-cessna says how significant are china uh
to russia and russia to china military relations
and could they become more significant uh given
attrition in the russian military at the moment